على مساحه تقدر ب 600 الف هكتار بدا
مزارعوه اثيوبيا حصاد القمح ومن المتوقع
انتاج نحو مليونين ونصف مليون طن وهي
المرحله الاولى من مبادره حكوميه تسعى
لتحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي ويسعى مزارعون
مستفيدون من المبادره الى زياده المساحات
المزروعه بادخال المكننه الزراعيه وانظمه
الري الحديثه بهدف زياده الانتاج
قليلا لكننا الان نستخدم المعدات الاليه
وقد تضاعف انتاج ثلاث مرات كما ان استخدام
الري بدلا من انتظار الامطار ساعدنا في ان
يكون لدينا دورتان زراعيتان في العالم بدل
دوره واحده
جيرانكم طلبه يا بابا
لكن هذه الخطه لا تخلو من تحديات من
ابرزيها تهريب القمح خارج البلاد لذا تشدد
وزاره الزراعه اثناء فتره الحصاد الرقابه
والمعاقبه مثلا
احدى المشاكل التي تواجهنا هي عمليات
تهريب القمح خصوصا من الحقول الواقعه على
الحدود الوزاره تتعامل بحسم مع هذه
الظاهره التي لا تؤثر على خطاتنا للتنصيل
بل حتى على احتياجات السوق المحلي
وتنتظر مئات المشاريع الزراعيه دورها في
التطوير والتحولات من نمط الزراعه
التقليديه الى الحديثه حيث من المقرر ان
تبلغ مساحه الاراضي المطوره خلال عامين
قرابه مليونيه كثار ستعمل على سد الفجوه
بين الاستهلاك والانتاج المحلي وتصدير
الفائض منه بحلول عام 2025
[موسيقى]
ولو خبراء واقتصاد اثيوبيون ان احد الدروس
المستخلصه من تداعيات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا ان السياده الغذائيه لم تعد
خيارا بل اولويه القصوى ينبغي تحقيقها
وهذا ما تسعى اليه مبادره قمح الاثيوبيه
عبر تعزيز الانتاج المحلي وتقليل
الاعتمادي على الاستيراد حسن الرزاق
الجزيره
جنوبيه اثيوبيا